the feared greed index one month so it's
zero to a hundred hundred is like
full-on greed zero is like shockingly
fearful
um
right now one month ago one year ago we
were at 28 28 just to put in perspective
that's when crypto started falling yeah
absolute fear extreme fear mode a month
ago it was 38 which was essentially fear
mode essentially way less than neutral
now today we're at 68 which is like
trending towards extreme gear agreed so
I don't know what's happening in the
economy over the last month but some of
these numbers inflation going down
employment being strong I don't know I
can't make sense of it is like is the
economy in shambles are we doing better
than ever are people greedy or people
fearful
[Music]
[Applause]